[Musica]
chicchissimi sì
[Applauso]
cosa ci stanno a scuola luca strano
[Musica]
[Applauso]
il mio libro mi hanno rubato hanno preso
storie paurose o no a chi vuol chi non
sta regalando a chi si fissi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
dobbiamo recuperarlo dobbiamo riprendere
il mio libro si saranno rubato
[Applauso]
che schifo
certo c'è stato scampo
[Applauso]
venga ripreso gestiti
ho sconfitto questi mesi non ci posso
prendere un conflitto femministi ma
vitale dove e dopo lavoro di moggi
presto andiamo
tutti qua
buio
è
meglio che mi racconto quartiere 0
ricordiamo si
[Musica]
no
a chi moticea presto presto dobbiamo
recuperare nel mio libro storie paurose
poi ce l'avete l'avete preso non potete
non avere storie paurose a scolari
misteri sono dell'essere che vi
piaceranno tantissimo ora presto
svegliamoci dobbiamo entrare nella
classe in cui c'erano kissing fiera
chiuovi a recuperare libro ma non
facciamoci prendere questa volta
ricordiamo per la abbiamo il grappa
questo abbiamo colpirà di huachipato che
si stima che mi va bene e la cosa mi
piace passato perché si faccia di
sanremo 6 10 mila mi piace giocheremo
nuovamente radio mondi nella vita reale
teniamoci detto
questo sì il libro e con che
presto con i premi
o no se da più anni già preso di nuovo
dobbiamo tornare in quella classe
vediamo se riusciamo a recuperare il
nostro libro facciamo così faccio così
non più libri
ski fiemme e di non posso vuol dire
faccio colpi non possiamo far bene
prendi la mira del formezpa servirà
moltissimo power da burdisso
cucina
o mista guardava mista guardava
finché non si è mosso siccome non si
muove posso provare a prendere il libro
così
secondo paul ii una bolina l'uso
pubblico e va bene si provò
[Applauso]
o
ci sei riuscito vediamo
voi sapete dove sta partire
o
no ha chiuso a rinchiuso qualcuno siamo
altro ancora
ci sia meno
forse lo abbiamo sconfitto perché
l'abbiamo creato con mano rossa di
confidare puntando alla mano pochissimi
si e l'ho messa ko o di paste potreste
aver eliminato di un logico numero blu
siamo
facciamo scappare dalla scuola
dovrebbe essere qua linguaggio guarda
non c'è più
sparito ma allora vuol dire che non
abbiamo eliminato vuol dire che avevano
quanti non sa potrebbe essersi nascosto
dietro una porta stai attenta
no
guardate anche questa rotta si è rotta e
ora come faremmo è inutilizzabile questo
non possiamo più colpirlo si aspetta
forse questi lontano con questa mano
tipo così guiderà si pronunci una testa
così vicina troppo vicini forse si
arrabbierà ancora di più se facciamo
così andiamo a vedere dove la mano blu
seguire un conflitto kiss tv si dovrebbe
esserci anche la mano un nome di
ricercarne sarà presto
nella classe zia
ma anche gli stilisti parità eppure son
sicura di aver la fontina
[Applauso]
e anche questo sia rotta e
partecipe ma ti sembra il momento
dobbiamo scappare da questa scuola si ma
che torni a bimbi ma visto che abbiamo
recuperato il libro ea di uomini non si
vede più neanche chi si missy scappiamo
direttamente riuscita ed il vero
scappiamo subito questi saremo liberi
l'avremmo anche vinto la challenge si
presto andiamocene subito via
vita verità
ma questa è l'uscita
qui possiamo dare ma non ti sembra tutto
un po troppo
silenzioso così
si è certo semplice ma veniamo alla
scala va beh
[Applauso]
per un bene se quello sì che è scappato
anche qualche per un pelo ci stavo per
prendere nascosto lì nelle scale apposta
per non farci scappare
dobbiamo assolutamente lavorare un piano
altrimenti non riusciremo mai a scappare
cometa scuola
forse sì
non c'è più
non c'è più ma non possiamo rischiare
scendere nuovamente fiscale perché lui
potrebbe sempre essere lì dobbiamo fare
una trappola in modo tale che lui ci
casca dentro noi possiamo scappare via
sì ma che tipo di trappola non è facile
con aghi guardie potentissimo e aspetto
momento a chi vuole il mio libro storie
paurose quindi potremo posizionare il
mio libro come esca
oppure che cosa ho un'idea che lui sta
cercando chi si misti perché innamorato
di questi mesi facciamo finta che chi si
misti e tornata facciamo iberti che fa
chi si messi e vediamo se riusciamo ad
attirarlo fa e poi guarda quasi una
porta che
questa volta forse si chiude cerchiamo
di capire come si chiude moderation
chiederanno bencaster beta tattico così
noi possiamo scappare presto controllo
prevenzione forse guardare dice qualcosa
che si muove
su vediamo
sì
perciò la possiamo impressionare anche
molti allora noi si stimola questa parte
possiamo qui scappar sì dobbiamo stare
superattenti questo piano deve
funzionare al 100 per cento altrimenti i
laghi modici prenderei rimarremo noi
imprigionati non muovo
allora iniziamo con il piano kissi mi si
ok faccia kissi missy ok
speriamo che funzioni iq anni
[Musica]
arrivando continuo ritardo
accumulati
in definitiva continua previsti anche
qua
[Musica]
vitale ma dove sei finito
io dico di no
ma che stai facendo
no per fortuna non esiste mozione niente
né in apribile per la morte non ci credo
ce lo facciamo per fortuna siamo
riusciti a fermarlo chievo vuole fare è
chiamare questa sua bonaria prenderci
hawking via piana
[Applauso]
[Musica]